[Musik]
die Ostsee hier suchen Urlauber Erholung
und treffen auf ein ganz besonderes
Lebensgefühl ein ruhiges Meer bekannt
für regenhandel und friedliches
Miteinander
all das ist jetzt bedroht seit der
mächtigen Nachbar Russland die Ukraine
angegriffen hat was macht das mit den
Menschen an der Ostsee
neun Länder teilen sich die Ufer des
Baltischen Meeres von Deutschland und
Polen über Teile Skandinaviens bis hin
zum Baltikum und ganz na Russland mit
seiner Exklave Kaliningrad und St
Petersburg
wir reisen an diese Orte suchen
Begegnungen mit Menschen die uns Ihren
Alltag zeigen
und wir fragen wie dieser sich verändert
hat mitten in einem neuen
machtpolitischen Spannungsfeld
[Musik]
mag die Welt auch Kopf stehen auf Rügen
scheint sie in Ordnung der Tag ist noch
frisch die Ostsee gehört den
Frühaufstehern wie Andreas Schiller die
Ostsee der Blick des Meer der Strand die
Luft die Geräusche alles zusammen ich
würde mal sagen besser
geht's nicht
[Musik]
ich bin in Binz Lieblings Siebert auf
einer der Lieblingsinsel der Deutschen
Rügens Ostküste eine Goldküste
ein kleines Stück heile Welt für jeden
[Musik]
doch Andreas der Jogi spürt die Welt
ändert sich alles fließt man sieht ja
hier auch sehr viele Tanker wenn man
hier früh morgens ist sieht man ja
ständig diesen diese Bewegung dieser
Industrie also diese Sache bleibt nicht
unberührt die sind ständiger Veränderung
vor der Küste schwimmt eine Gasfabrik
und noch eine soll kommen für Jahre in
einem nahen Hafen andocken verflüssigtes
Erdgas erwärmen und einspeisen in Europa
diese Röhren sind übrig von Nord Stream
2 einer jener Pipelines die russische
Gas lieferten bis sie explodierten nun
sollen die Röhren den gasnetzanschluss
ermöglichen in einem 5 Meter breiten
Graben quer durch die Bucht ein Risiko
für die Umwelt und fürs
[Musik]
im Kursaal ist die Mehrheit gegen den
Plan
zur Notwendigkeit
der
aus Berlin ist ein Beamter aus dem
Wirtschaftsministerium angereist er
trifft auf ein genervtes Land
meine Damen und Herren lassen
mit der Presse darf er nicht reden im
Kern steht die Frage wie viel Gas
braucht Deutschland
bei Baubeginn droht ein Rechtsstreit
Binz gegen den Bund ich treffe den
Tourismus Chef auf der Seebrücke egal
was Richter entscheiden große Politik
drängt in die heile Welt das ist ein
mittlerweile geopolitisch total
sensibler Raum hier die Ostsee direkt
vor der Insel Rügen wir haben ja neuen
Anrainerstaaten hier im Kontext der
baltischen See
höchst sensibel für die einen ist es das
Tor zum Atlantik für die anderen ist das
Umwelt Lebensraum aber auch energietr
mehr Gebiet auf Rügen fühlen sich viele
als spielmasse in einem Machtpoker das
Idyll ist gestört der Wandel nervt die
Weltpolitik wirbelt einiges auf und
nicht nur hier
[Musik]
die Ostsee ist eines der
verkehrsreichsten Seegebiete der Welt
besonders deutlich sieht man das hier am
Tor zur Ostsee dem großen Bild mehr als
20.000 Schiffe passieren das Gebiet
jährlich Millionen Tonnen von Fracht
werden hier transportiert
mich überrascht das viele Schiffe aus
russischen Häfen kommen trotz der
Sanktionen gegen Putins Russland warum
ist das so
Antworten erhoff ich mir von denen die
die sie kennen wie ihre Westentasche den
Lotsen
sie nehmen mich mit zu den großen
Schiffen auf hoher See
Morton green und Frank Schmidt erzählen
mir dass manche Reedereien entschieden
haben nicht mehr mit Russland zusammen
zu arbeiten
gut beschäftigt sind die Lotsen trotzdem
andere Schiffe aus China der Türkei oder
Indien zum Beispiel haben das Geschäft
übernommen also die Summe der Schiffe
die hier unterwegs sind hat sich glaube
ich nicht groß verändert
nach Europa und in die USA dürfen
russische Rohstoffe nicht verschifft
werden durch aus aber in den Nahen Osten
nach Indien oder China
Russland darf in solche Drittstaaten
sogar Öl exportieren solange der
Weltmarktpreis 60 $ pro fast nicht
überschreitet wo die Fracht am Ende
wirklich ankommt scheint völlig offen
[Musik]
das Kohle und Öl werden einen Weg finden
das ist die Weltwirtschaft
lass sie mit der Fracht machen ob sie
sie irgendwo von einem Schiff auf ein
anderes umladen oder irgendwas mit den
Papieren anstellen oder Öl in Indien
verarbeiten das weiß ich nicht
aber indien hat nie Erdöl produziert wie
können sie plötzlich Öl exportieren wenn
sie es nicht irgendwoher bekommen haben
auf 8 Knoten soll die auf den
marschallinsel registrierte Lex ihre
Geschwindigkeit reduzieren damit das
Lotsen Boot längsseits gehen kann
bei seinen Einsätzen ist Frank immer mit
seinem kleinen Reisekoffer unterwegs
denn er ist oft tagelang auf See um
Schiffe zu lotsen nach ein paar Stunden
geht es für ihn dann schon zum nächsten
Chef der Umstieg jedes Mal ein gewagtes
oben angekommen treffen Lotsen immer
wieder auf gemischte Besatzungen aus
Russen und Ukraine die gehen hoch
professionell miteinander um erfahre ich
mit an Bord darf ich aber nicht
wie geht es den Lotsen damit Exporte zu
unterstützen mit denen Russland seinen
Krieg finanziert
hier geht es um Sicherheit nicht um
Politik für mich ist das ein Schiff das
um Lotsen bittet wenn ich mich
entscheiden würde als Lotse nicht zu
helfen und nicht für größtmögliche
Sicherheit zu sorgen sondern stattdessen
zu sagen ich mache das nicht wegen der
Politik und das Schiff läuft aufgrund
und Unmengen von Öl verschmutzen ganz
Dänemark dann hätte ich sicher das
Gefühl die falsche Entscheidung
getroffen zu haben
Mortens Heimat ist die Insel Bornholm
wie ein Flugzeugträger wiegt sie mitten
in der Ostsee hier gibt es einen
ständiges Schaulaufen der Kriegsschiffe
von Russland und der NATO ich treffe den
Mann mit der wohl spektakulärsten
Aussicht auf die Ostsee Bremen ist
Landwirt
beunruhigen ihn die Vorboten eines neuen
Kalten Krieges da draußen
wir haben schon ein paar mal erlebt dass
da draußen eine Menge Schiffe lagen
das war sicher weil die Sorge bestand
dass da etwas passiert
plötzlich wurde präben Teil dieser
Kriegsspiele als Russland immer mehr
Truppen um die Ukraine in Stellung
brachte nahm Dänemarks Militär seinen
Hof ins Visier den ich Offiziere fuhren
vor und klopften an seine Tür
[Musik]
sie sind gekommen und haben höflich
gefragt ob Sie hier eine Radarstation
aufbauen dürfen
ich hatte kein Problem damit also habe
ich gesagt klar das dürfte
ich habe mir auch keine Sorgen gemacht
oder Fragen gestellt für mich ist das
ganz normal dass wir einander helfen und
aufeinander aufpassen so weit das
möglich ist
kurz vor dem letzten Winter haben die
Militärs ihre Anlagen wieder abgebaut
warum ist Bremen völlig unklar
interessiert ihn aber auch nicht sein
Feld will er bald wieder in Ordnung
bringen
in Dänemark lassen Sie sich vom
Machtpoker der Weltmächte offenbar nicht
aus der Ruhe bringen
am anderen Ufer der Ostsee in Polen
leben viele Menschen die deswegen fast
alles verloren haben
[Musik]
in Swinemünde an der polnischen
Ostseeküste treffe ich olina 33 geflohen
aus der Nähe von Kiew sie hat polnisch
gelernt und Arbeit gefunden wie viele
geflohene in Polen 13 Millionen Ukraine
sind nach Kriegsbeginn ins Nachbarland
gekommen etwa 1,5 Millionen sind
geblieben wie Olena
am ersten Tag als ich ans Meer kam ging
ich an dieser Bar vorbei und das hat mir
sehr gefallen
mehr Sonnenschein es war mein Traum am
Strand und am Meer zu arbeiten
Polen ist einer der großen Unterstützer
der Ukraine die Solidarität gewaltig
ukrainische geflohene bekommen
unbürokratisch eine Registrierungsnummer
können arbeiten haben Recht auf
Sozialleistungen
als ich das erste Mal zur Arbeit kam
fragte der Chef ob ich in einem
schwarzen T-Shirt kommen kann ich sagte
ich habe kein schwarzes T-Shirt also
schon aber das ist in der Ukraine ich
bin ja ohne irgendwas gekommen
und zwei drei Tage später brachten mir
meine Kollegen was zu Hause vorbei
sie gaben mir einige Sachen Rosen und
T-Shirts alles
Mann ist in der Nähe von Kiew geblieben
Männer zwischen 18 und 60 dürfen nicht
raus aus der Ukraine das Land muss
verteidigt werden
ich war zu Hause mit meinem Mann und
unserem Hündchen und eine Rakete traf
unser Gebäude und das halbe Haus war weg
zwei Stunden lang konnte ich nichts mehr
hören mein Mann hatte eine verletzte
Hand
der Hund ist weg vielleicht ist der Tod
es war sehr beängstigend ich dachte ich
würde sterben der Strand die sie das
beruhigt sie manchmal stehe sie da und
beneide sich selbst weil es hier so
schön sei sagt sie die so viel verloren
hat
regelmäßig trifft sie sich mit titana
auch aus der Ukraine sie sprechen
bewusst nicht über den Krieg weil sie
schon von zu Hause die vielen schlimmen
Nachrichten bekommen
olina zeigt uns Fotos die sie selbst
gemacht hat auf der Flucht
mit Opfern in den Autos sagt sie
ich hasse Russland weil sie normale
Menschen angegriffen haben nicht die
ukrainische Armee sondern Zivilisten
und sie haben solche Dinge getan ich
hasse sie
olina und titana haben sich hier
kennengelernt das Schicksal verbindet
Frieden Freiheit wann wird es das wieder
bei Euch geben frage ich
Freiheit wenn Putin stirbt ja wenn Putin
stirbt wir warten sehr auf diesen Moment
darauf dass es endet
die Ostsee das Wasser Polens
Freundschaft das alles hilft und dennoch
nichts wünschen sie sich sehnlicher als
zurückzukehren in ihrer Heimat die
Ukraine
[Musik]
weiter nördlich an der Küste verbunden
durch die Ostsee und doch liegen Welten
dazwischen St Petersburg vom
energieriesengasprom bis zur
Söldnertruppe Wagner viele die Russlands
Schicksal bestimmen haben hier ihren
Hauptsitz ich weiß nicht wie offen die
Menschen hier mit mir sprechen werden
denn Moskau aus Zensurgesetze stellen
alles unter Strafe was nicht der Haltung
des Regimes entspricht
Vitali will Kapitän werden wir reden
über seine Heimatstadt seine
Zukunftspläne als ich Frage inwiefern
der Krieg sein Leben verändert habe
erzählt Vitali das Kommilitonen von ihm
gefallen sind ich merke dass er seine
Worte mit Bedacht wählt
das ist natürlich sehr schwer
andererseits worauf die Jungs gehofft
hatten ist unklar
vielleicht wollten sie Geld verdienen
vielleicht haben Sie irgendwelche
patriotischen Gefühle verspürt ich weiß
es nicht
das Vitali studiert schützt ihn vor der
Einberufung zum Militär
seine getöteten Kommilitonen hatten sich
freiwillig gemeldet
sie sind natürlich Helden ich will in
keiner Weise ihre Arbeit abwerten
aber es ist doch traurig dass die
Regierung dass die Menschen die sich mit
Politik beschäftigen was so weit kommen
lassen
Vitali ist verheiratet mit einer
Ukrainerin die 2014 vor den Kämpfen in
Johannes geflohen ist
ihre Familie lebt noch dort
uns bewegt natürlich was ich ereignet
wie wir vorrücken wie die Ukraine
Vorankommen diese Nachrichten verfolgen
wir
aber ständig in dieser Realität zu leben
das ist unmöglich zumindest für mich
mein Gehirn schottet sich da irgendwie
ab
ich weiß nicht ich denke überhaupt nicht
mehr darüber nach
Ablenkung als Selbstschutz schweigen aus
Angst dazu ein Gefühl der Machtlosigkeit
das Russland nach Jahren der
Repressionen fest im Griff hat
doch nicht alle wurden davon erfasst in
diesem Hinterhof lebt das Gewissen von
St Petersburg so nennen Sie Jelena hier
die 77-Jährige erholt sich nur langsam
von einem Schlaganfall doch sie wollte
unser Treffen partout nicht absagen
die Künstlerin kämpft gegen den Krieg
gegen die Teilnahmslosigkeit ihrer
Mitmenschen auch wenn sie manche Gründe
dafür nachvollziehen kann
es gibt recht viele Menschen die alles
verstehen
sie kommen dann heran zu mir ich im
Rollstuhl sitze und sagen wenn ich
protestiere verliere ich den Job
verliere ich alles
verstehen sie die Gesetze sind jetzt so
geschrieben worden
immer wieder stellt sich Jelena mit
ihren Plakaten auf die Straße alleine
jedes Mal endet das mit einem
Polizei-Einsatz wie viele Geldstrafen
sie schon kassiert hat weiß sie nicht
jelenas neueste Botschaft Russland
bedarf einer Rehabilitierung nach
schwerer Krankheit
in welche Richtung hat sich Deutschland
damals bewegt
wir haben jetzt genau die gleiche
schwere Krankheit wie einst Deutschland
[Musik]
wenn alles vorbei sei sagt Jelena werde
es noch lange dauern bis die russische
Gesellschaft geheilt sei
liberale Werte werden von der russischen
Politik verteufelt Freiheiten
abgeschafft der Westen geht auf Distanz
und Russland schottet sich ab auch von
ehemals guten Nachbarn
[Musik]
Finnland war mal so ein guter Nachbar im
Grenzgebiet zu Russland will ich sehen
wie sich der Alltag der Menschen dort
verändert hat die Grenzübergänge sind
nur noch tagsüber geöffnet die
ausreisekontrollen sind scharf keine
Computer keine Elektronik über den
Eigenbedarf hinaus dürfen in Putins
Reich so wollen ist die Sanktionen
auch für die Einreise gelten strenge
Beschränkungen
wir müssen genauer hingucken
Regeln sehr genau wer noch nach Finnland
einreisen kann nur noch wenige Russen
dürfen über die Grenze
Familienangehörige Leute die in Finnland
arbeiten oder studieren
mit ihren Papieren müssen sich Reisende
aus Russland bei grenzkontrolleuren und
dem Zoll anstellen eine lange Prozedur
die Alexandra schon kennt die Russin
macht dem finnischen Helsinki eine
Ausbildung zur Köchin und erlebt die
Situation in beiden Ländern
das ist alles sehr kompliziert es ist
mein Heimatland dass ich sehr liebe und
wo ich aufgewachsen bin
aber wenn man dann nach Europa kommt ist
das viel friedlicher so fühlt sich das
an
es ist einfach kompliziert
nicht nur Alexandra tut sich schwer mit
dieser neuen Ordnung für viele Menschen
aus Russland hat der Konflikt das Leben
nicht einfacher gemacht
bis vor kurzem war so ein Grenzübertritt
noch kein Problem heute werden sich die
Nachbarn wieder fremd
auf der finnischen Seite hat sich nur
wenig verändert
für Pecker war und bleibt Russland ein
großer und unberechenbarer Nachbar
gleich dort hinter seinem Gartenzaun
dort wo große Schilder davor warnen sich
der Grenze auch nur zu nähern
das ist die erste Linie der russischen
Grenze ich darf hier noch weitergehen
sie nicht
okay
tschüss tschüss ich kann gehen
er darf weitergehen weil er dort lebt
da ist die richtige Grenze wir sind ganz
dicht dran
die Finnen waren stets wachsam wenn es
um die Grenze zu ihrem Nachbarn im Osten
ging
in ihrer Neutralität hatten sie sich
aber ganz gut eingerichtet
Hacker fährt mit mir raus zu Caroline
und ihrem Mann die beiden Fischer haben
Reusen in Sichtweite der Grenze zu
Russland ausgelegt
ob sie ihren Fang wohl noch nach
Russland verkaufen können
ich glaube wir verkaufen jetzt gar
nichts mehr nach Russland wir gehen nach
doch Maria wie und wir leben in yonisu
dort verkaufen wir den Großteil unserer
Fische und auch in Helsinki
[Musik]
sie reden darüber wie Russlands neue
Aggressivität hier im Osten Finnlands
die Wirtschaft ab wirkt sie fürchten
dass die Zeit offener Grenzen vorbei ist
eine Zeit von Aufschwung und Wohlstand
von länderübergreifenden Freundschaften
es hatte sich etwas verändert was daran
lag dass es eine Zeit gab in der die
Grenze offen war
sie war für uns Zivilisten offen und es
gab sehr viele Kontakte mit russischen
Freunden wir haben dort gearbeitet jetzt
gibt es das nicht mehr
aber wie lange das andauern wird das
wissen wir nicht das weiß niemand von
uns
Putins Angriff auf die Ukraine hat hier
das Machtgefüge verändert Finnland hat
sich entschieden als Teil der NATO
Russland die Grenzen ihre Nachbarschaft
aufzuzeigen die Ostsee ein zunehmend
politischer Raum denn notfalls
militärisch geschützt werden muss
[Musik]
sie radeln sie rennen beim Alarmstart
zählt jede Sekunde Kampfjets aus
Rumänien auf dem Stützpunkt schaulei in
Litauen
jede dieser F16 muss innerhalb von 15
Minuten in der Luft sein das ist die
Vorgabe das üben sie
die Nato will der Welt zeigen sie
schützt hier den Luftraum das rumänische
Geschwader ist gerade für vier Monate da
einer der Piloten trägt den Bordfunk den
Rufnamen Mütze
das Gefühl im echten Einsatz ist noch
mal ganz anders als im Training
aber sobald wir in der Luft sind und wir
unsere geübten Abläufe umsetzen dann
fühlt es sich gut an
man fühlt sich richtig wohl
wie oft wird es echt wie oft fangen sie
Flugzeuge ab es kommt ganz darauf an
es gibt Wochen mit zehn Alarm einsetzen
oder auch mehr und dann gibt es Wochen
da steigen wir gar nicht auf was kommt
wirklich darauf an
es kommt an auf die NATO auf Russland
und darauf dass beide Seiten kühle Köpfe
bewahren
[Applaus]
über der Ostsee gehen fast täglich zwei
Weltmächte auf Tuchfühlung seit
Russlands Krieg gegen die Ukraine fliegt
die NATO hier noch öfter
darf ich eine Frage stellen
die sind so nah ist das nicht gefährlich
nein das ist Formationsflug das lernst
du im Pilotentraining das ist zuerst
nicht einfach aber wenn du es drauf hast
ist es wie Schwimmen oder Radfahren
du kannst das mit geschlossenen Augen
der Pilot im Airbus zieht Schleifen über
Schäfchen Wolken trainiert mit seinen
Kameraden in deutschen Euro weiter einer
zeigt was er unterm Flügel hat es ist
eine Warnung beim Abfangen Einsatz der
wird geflogen wenn ein Pilot keine
Position sendet nicht auf Funk reagiert
womöglich nicht entdeckt werden will
den Ernstfall Film vor kurzem ein
britischer Pilot
links und in der Mitte russische
Militärflugzeug rechts ein Jet aus
Schweden sie fliegen über der Ostsee an
der Grenze zum nato-luftraum und trennen
sich erst als die Russen abdrehen
abfangen Manöver fliegen beide Seiten
seit Jahren über allen Lehren drohen nun
auch in der Ostsee gefährliche
Flugbewegungen wie diese
im Airbus fliegen wir rund um die Ostsee
der Belgier Harald van P hat den Befehl
über die NATO Kampfjets im Norden der
Ostflanke wir nähern uns der russischen
Exklave Kaliningrad und die staune wie
gesittet die Umgangsformen in diesem
Luftraum sind
es bräuchte doch nur einen kleinen
Pilotenfehler und dann gäbe seine
Eskalation die keiner wollte
[Musik]
das kann immer passieren aber wir wollen
das vermeiden
wenn die Russen zum Beispiel einen
alarmeinsatz fliegen dann lassen wir
unsere Jets auch mal am Boden
sie sollen sich nicht in die Quere
kommen gerade vor Kaliningrad wollen wir
keine Missverständnisse und die auch
nicht
[Musik]
wir haben über der Ostsee noch ein gutes
Arbeitsverhältnis mit den Russen und ich
will dass es so bleibt
unten Schwedens Küste oben Schwedens
Luftwaffe das Land war neutral nähert
sich aber buchstäblich der NATO an
der Beitritt zum Bündnis ist noch nicht
endgültig Schweden aber ist schon NATO
kompatibel
so wird Russlands Spielraum in der
Ostsee kleiner ich frage den General
drei Jahrzehnte lang war das eine ruhige
Gegend ändert sich das jetzt
durch den Beitritt von Finnland und
hoffentlich bald auch von Schweden
verschieben sich die Gewichte ein wenig
aber bei dieser NATO-Mission da machen
wir eigentlich dasselbe wie in den
vergangenen Jahrzehnten
für sich genommen hat sie sich nicht
verändert
in meinen Ohren ist das anders Statement
der Auftrag ist der alte das Umfeld ist
neu die Ostsee wird ein Meer der NATO
dagegen steht Russlands Machtanspruch
das hat Konfliktpotenzial
[Musik]
Russlands Machtanspruch bestimmte auch
im lettischen leoparia das Leben der
Menschen zu der Stadt gehört carosta
einst Militärstützpunkte Zarenzeit
später der Sowjets direkt am
Ostseestrand hier siedelten damals die
Sowjets Russinnen und Russen an bis
heute hat etwa ein Viertel der
lettischen Bevölkerung russische Wurzeln
man liebt den Parallelwelten
[Musik]
der alte Kriegshafen ist immer noch da
mit seinem ausgedienten Militärgefängnis
für Soldaten
auch heute kann man sich hier anschreien
und demütigen lassen wenn man dafür
zahlt
ich habe noch was interessant im gesucht
unter fiel mir das vor die Füße und da
sind wir
mein Mann hat mir das zum Geburtstag
geschenkt
romantisches Wochenende
Dieter und Jannis sind aus der Nähe von
Riga 21 Uhr ein Samstagabend antreten zu
extrem-tour
alles aufsammeln alles
[Musik]
alle werden bestraft wenn einer ein
Idiot ist wie gerade Thomas
einmal sich fühlen wie ein
Gefängnisinsasse unter den Sowjets
damals
kannst du jetzt atmen jetzt
ein checken im Militär Knast gehorsam
ist oberstes Gebot die Truppe ist sofort
tief drin im Spiel wie Jannis
die Geschichten der uns erzählt hat das
hat mich echt nachdenklich gemacht über
unsere dunklen Zeiten der Geschichte
keine Fragen angespannte Stimmung nicht
zerstören klare Ansage an mich nach
einer Stunde traue ich mich vorsichtig
wozu das ganz um himmels will
es ist jetzt etwas anderes solche Fragen
zu beantworten denn seit letztem Jahr
seit Februar 2022 haben viele Kollegen
ihre Uniform geändert von sowjetisch zu
neutral
weil wir mit beiden Regimen dem
russischen und dem sowjetischen nichts
zu tun haben wollen dieser Tage
schon gar nicht sie glorifizieren
aber Geschichte zeigen und sie sich
merken das kann man doch viel besser mit
so einer Erfahrung hier
die sowjetischen Zeiten hier das war
ziemlich genau das was gerade in der
Ukraine passiert
wir verstehen Sie
wir helfen Ihnen so gut das geht
drei Stunden drin Bleisch wäre Munition
transportieren die Zeit zieht sich man
leidet mit
[Musik]
das war echt eine interessante Übung wir
mussten diese Granate tragen die ist
extrem schwer so etwa 40 Kilo
das war bestimmt Absicht nur zwei von
uns haben das geschafft da habe ich
gefühlt es wurde mir klar wie schwierig
das für die Soldaten in der Ukraine ist
ihr Land zu verteidigen extrem schwierig
die Drangsalierung geht weiter
eigentlich bin ich nur Beobachterin doch
dann die Anweisung an mich ran an die
Wand
ich tue es komme da nicht raus
funktioniere ein merkwürdiges Gefühl
der nächste Morgen es ist vorbei der
Drill die Demütigung die Nacht in der
Zelle all das wird noch spürbar nach
wie war die Nacht
das war jetzt nicht wie im Hotel
keine frische Luft Schimmel überall und
dann diese Art Bett aber ich habe es
geschafft war ist das wert
definitiv ich kann es nur jedem
empfehlen
wir alle haben Angst
das ist ein kollektives Trauma für alle
post sowjet-staaten
und
tief in uns drin haben wir Angst dass
das noch mal passieren könnte
muss man so etwas wirklich gemacht haben
ist das schräg zynisch oder eben gerade
nicht weil es hilft die aktuelle Lage
besser zu verstehen eine Antwort finde
ich so schnell nicht was ich aber
mitnehme auch wenn für sie die
naturmitgliedschaft als
Lebensversicherung gilt die Bedrohung
durch den alten Besatzer ist durchaus
wieder ein Thema in Lettland
[Musik]
vom lettischen Militärhafen zum
russischen wirtschaftshafen
an der Grenze zu Finnland liegt wieburg
von hier aus wurde russische Kohle unter
anderem nach Deutschland verschifft bis
die Sanktionen kamen
wieburg schickt immer noch Kohle nach
Europa nur kommt die jetzt aus
Kasachstan
hier bin ich mit Olga ansberg verabredet
der ersten und einzigen Frau Russlands
die einen Hafen leitet
die Arbeit am Wasser ist mir heilig ich
habe mein ganzes Leben lang davon
geträumt an der See zu arbeiten
seit Kriegsbeginn ist das Verhältnis zu
Finland unterkühlt
um logistikprobleme zu lösen müsse man
dem Nachbarn manchmal zu blinzeln verrät
Olga
weiter ins Detail gehen kann sie aber
nicht
das sagen
ich glaube das Interaktion und
Zusammenarbeit das Wichtigste sind
die normale Arbeit und der menschliche
Kontakte auf keinen Fall verloren gehen
darauf basieren Fortschritt Wohlstand
und Wohlbefinden
mehrere Kriege haben Russland und
Finnland gegeneinander geführt wie Burg
viel mal in die eine mal in die andere
Hand jetzt ist es ein eher gemütlicher
Teil Russlands
Millionen Touristen kamen 2022 doch
außerhalb der Altstadt Nähe an der
Grenze sind Besucher nicht überall
willkommen
westliche Journalisten wie ich schon mal
gar nicht der Geheimdienst will wissen
was wir hier drehen und erteilt mir
schließlich keine Genehmigung zum
Grundstück von Ilias Laptop zu fahren
mein russisches Team besucht ihn ohne
mich per Telefon sprechen wir über die
finnischen Landhäuser die hier
rekonstruiert
Ilja ist ein erfolgreicher Onkologe er
zeigt meinem Team womit er seit sechs
Jahren jede freie Minute verbringt
Museen und Herbergen sollen hier
entstehen einen Weinkeller gibt es schon
und selbst gebrautes Starkbier das
liefert Ilja an Restaurants in der
Umgebung
der Russe lässt das finnische Erbe des
Dorfes kieskeller wieder aufleben
während zwischen Moskau und Finnland
Eiszeit herrscht
wir Russen sind seit 1000 Jahren mit den
Finnen verheiratet in dieser Zeit ist
alles mögliche passiert aber das ist
kein Grund sich scheiden zu lassen so
ist das in einer Familie
kieskeller ist ein beliebtes
Ausflugsziel die Besucher wollten sehen
wie durch den Bauprozess schönes
entstehe meint ihr ja wichtig sei das
vor allem nach den letzten Monaten
die russischen Menschen jetzt etwas
Positives die Motivation etwas zu
erschaffen sie wollen sehen dass sich
das Land in eine bessere Richtung
entwickelt
im kleinen magneus entstehen doch
politisch werden die Uhren in Russland
gerade zurückgedreht
Innovationsgeist Unternehmertum alles
wird Moskau aus machtpolitischen Zielen
untergeordnet
noch sind nicht alle Folgen die der
Krieg gegen die Ukraine auf die
russische Gesellschaft haben wird
absehbar
manche stechen sofort ins Auge
am Strand von Biburg treffe ich eine
Gruppe russischer Soldaten auf
Genesungsurlaub
sie alle haben in der Ostukraine
gekämpft
was ist passiert
eine Drohne ist über meinem Kopf
explodiert Helm und Schädeldecke würden
durchschlagen
hier sehen sie ein Opfer vom
Raketensystem heimers
wegen der Heimat hatte ich 12 gebrochene
Rippen wenn ich wieder gesund bin gehe
ich zurück egal ob sie mich wer tauglich
Stempeln oder nicht
dort gibt es so viele verwundete
deswegen muss ich auf jeden Fall zurück
Russland wird siegen
anders kann es nicht sein
bald werden wir unsere Flagge in Kiel
wissen
wann
sehr bald
wenn Europa sich nicht beruhigt
marschieren wir weiter dann wissen wir
unsere Flagge auch in Berlin so war es
1945 so wird es 2025 wieder sein
radikale Überzeugungen die Bereitschaft
für Moskaus Ziele zu sterben
sie mischen sich zwischen ausflugler und
Familien im Feierabend
kriegsrückkehrer die getötet haben und
Sterben sahen sie gehören mittlerweile
fest zu Russlands Alltag
[Musik]
solche radikalen Überzeugungen teilen
andere nicht
ich bin in Narva
nur ein Fluss trennt hier Estland von
Russland
das Lebensgefühl in der Stadt ist immer
noch russisch die Vorfahren zu
sowjetszeiten einst bewusst von Moskau
hier angesiedelt von hier aus ging ein
Video von Alina in den sozialen
Netzwerken viral mit Protest gegen Putin
mit Putin ist ein und das am 9
mai dem Tag des Sieges einem wichtigen
russischen Feiertag
ich habe mich mit Alina am Grenzfluss
verabredet auch sie hat russische
Wurzeln
es war verboten irgendwelche Poster
mitzubringen weil sie die Situation
ruhig halten wollten
es ist wirklich sehr gefährlich wenn
sich die Leute hier in Estland
untereinander streiten
und so war alles was Russland oder die
Ukraine unterstützt verboten
aber du kannst ja nicht jemandem einfach
ein T-Shirt ausziehen
während wir drehen regt sich hinter der
Kamera eine Passantin auf man solle die
Polizei wegen dieser
antiputin-propaganda rufen doch vor der
Kamera verstummt sie und verschwindet
die russische Seite beschallte von
drüben die estnische mit einem Konzert
und Kreml Propaganda die in Estland
gehört werden sollte
viele der Nachkommen der in Narva
angesiedelten Russen verehren noch den
starken Mann in Moskau und verfolgen nur
russische Medien
[Musik]
ich war einfach sehr verärgert weißt du
sie machen da drüben ein Konzert extra
für uns auf unserer Seite für unsere
estnische Seite das ist pure Provokation
es gibt dort dieses narrativ dass die
Leute hier bei uns im Grunde
eingeschränkt sind
für Touristen ist die Grenze zu wer
Familie hat auf beiden Seiten da hin und
her
offen über den Krieg in der Ukraine
sprechen eigentlich ein Tabu in Narva
Alina tut es trotzdem
natürlich hoffe ich dass die Ukraine
gewinnt aber gleichzeitig bin ich
besorgt was nach Putin kommt
wer wird das sein
die letzten Nachrichten zu pregorian
alle waren aufgeregt wie eine große
Revolution saß aus aber gleichzeitig
wolltest du pregorian an der Macht sehen
auch wenn man spürt dass hier viel
russischer Geist weht wir sind immer
noch in Island
Alina nimmt mich mit in ihre Welt sie
ist Lehrerin nach dem Protest gegen
Putin legte ihr die Schulleitung nahe zu
kündigen die 22-Jährige fühlt sich als
es den Punkt sie versucht mir dieses
russische trauern um die Vergangenheit
zu erklären
manchmal denke ich mir vielleicht war
das Leben für sie früher einfacher du
hattest eine Ideologie einen Job ein
Haus die gleichen Freunde aber jetzt ist
alles fragil und unsicher und du hast so
viel Auswahl du musst so viel Wissen und
kritisch denken das ist nicht mehr so
leicht
seit 1991 ist Island unabhängig einst
waren die Russen hier die bestimmer
jetzt sind sie nur noch die Minderheit
es gehen Risse durch Familien auch durch
die von Alina
ich sehe mich als Estin und ich liebe
meinen Vater klar wir haben
unterschiedliche politische Ansichten
wir haben verschiedene Meinungen zu
Identität
ich glaube das regt vor allem Ihnen auf
und meine Mama sagten mir machst du gut
aber wir haben trotzdem eine gute
Beziehung
also ist er pro Putin
kein Problem für dich nein
wir haben erhitzte Debatten manchmal
aber weißt du
wann wir uns einig sein werden wird die
Zeit zeigen die Zeit wird das sicher
nicht zeigen
[Musik]
Musiklehrerin Alina schreibt ihre
Gefühle in Lieder
[Musik]
sie würden aber nach dem Sommer
verlassen nicht mehr ihre Welt sie geht
in die Hauptstadt Tallinn
der Krieg gegen die Ukraine weckt an der
Ostsee Erinnerungen an alte Zeiten die
Angst vor dem ehemaligen Besatzer ist
wieder spürbar statt
länderübergreifender Freundschaften
entstehen neue Grenzen
im zweiten Teil unserer Reise begleiten
wir Minentaucher die Überreste
vergangener Kriege entschärfen
wir treffen Menschen die der russischen
Aggression trotzen und sich nicht
einschüchtern lassen und wir sind in der
russischen Exklave Kaliningrad umgeben
von der EU und doch abgeschottet er geht
weiter der Machtpoker an der Ostsee
[Musik]